grant chaps is here morning morning how
are you nice to see you thanks for
joining us on the programme um what
happened
in terms of your campaign yeah so i came
in obviously very late in the day and um
but uh got off to a good start the rules
were then actually changed they doubled
the nomination figures from previously
in order to speed through the
competition because we're keen to have a
new leader in place i would have been
nominated on the old rules i thought
probably not on the new rules and in any
case looking at the candidates talking
to all the candidates as i was doing
throughout i actually came to a
conclusion that another candidate had
the right policies and could uh be
certainly be ready to do the job on day
one as he walked into downing street and
that's of course rishi
politics is brutal though isn't it isn't
it
how do you feel about it this morning um
you know i uh very much enjoyed my time
in the race i think i came and spoke to
you here on no not me
sophie sorry on on sunday
um i was in the studio on sunday and uh
as i say you know i enjoyed the uh race
i was able to put forward my platform i
would have on the previous rules uh been
nominated the um the the rules will
switch uh but as i say rishi uh has a
good plan which it was the closest to
the things that i was i'm saying in
terms of the need to tackle inflation
the need to grow the economy uh and so i
was pleased to back him and here we are
well you say that but let me just remind
of our viewers a couple of things that
you said and tell me why you've now
folded in behind rishi sunak um you
pledged to halt the planned rising
corporation tax cut income tax by a
penny and spend three percent of gdp on
uh defense um
at the time which is called those sort
of pledges fairy tales and arbitrary
tasks yes he wasn't calling that's but
he was other people's the generality but
let's just sort of look at this politics
is of course about finding the best
route through and we're grown-ups you
have to look at where compromises exist
he is raising uh defense spending to two
and a half percent i said three he's
raising it to two and a half from two
two point three at the moment uh he is
planning to bring down corporation uh
sorry uh uh uh private individual tax
you know the basic rate uh from 20 to 19
piece who's doing that albeit that i was
saying or couldn't it be done a bit
quicker but he is moving in that
direction he has just this week last
week delivered the biggest tax cut that
we've had for a generation uh with um
you know a huge change in the you know
that we've got the highest national
insurance for 70 years haven't you yeah
absolutely we've had the overcome really
you know we've had the only um pandemic
that we've had for over a hundred years
and yes it's added cost to it that's
true but i mean you're you you okay so
even if you're saying that you're you're
trying to do a similar thing he was
saying it was a fairy tale to try to do
it in the time scale that you and others
have suggested yeah so we had there was
a range wasn't there just to explain
this there was a range of
different uh you know manifesto
commitments and some people saying they
would go a lot further and a lot faster
uh i was saying probably something in
between those candidates and what rishi
was saying and so as i looked around
pretty logically i'm looking for the
person who was closest to my position
and actually i thought had the
credibility to do it and i think the
reason that rishi has both of those
things is that
he recognizes as i did
that inflation is the biggest single
issue that we must tackle at 10 it's
extremely high and the first thing to do
is to tackle that the second thing to do
is to go further with tax cuts and as he
said yesterday when he launched it's not
a question of if there will be tax cuts
there'll be a question of when there's
tax cuts and that's rishi's policy and
again i thought that was the right and
responsible okay reese mog says he's a
socialist i mean he's saying it as a
that's a dirty word um what do you think
it's just look i i think it's best if we
just concentrate on the positives for
each of our um candidates and avoid sort
of uh perhaps others wouldn't agree but
in this context quite extreme language
well i mean clearly a guy who um you
know is fiscally conservative uh wants
to get the debt and and deficit down and
debt falling as a proportion of the
overall economy i mean the idea that
this is you know socialist is clearly
not true but as i say i i think and this
is what i'll be doing um
throughout this campaign it's best to
focus on what you have to offer now
uh
jacob is supporting a different
candidate um she'll be able to say what
she supports rishi can say what he
supports people the membership will
eventually make that judgment and i
think that is far better than trading
sort of you know uh disparaging comments
as this was intended what do you think
about suggestions that we should
withdraw from the european convention on
human rights uh well look the european
conventional team writes something that
we helped set up has uh its purpose uh i
haven't specifically spoken to arishi
about the uh issue but i don't think
that it would be
a an early priority the main thing is to
get the laws working as we need them for
us to make a better life for the people
of europe the only people that are not
in it are belarus and russia i think
well that's as i say well i don't think
it's part of
any platform here just to just to
clarify what so um what then well let me
ask you about nadine doris first of all
um she's talking about
dark arts and dirty tricks your
campaigns always split the party don't
they well look a leadership campaign by
brutal by the very nature again
of course do you have the potential to
um bring out differences on the plus
side when they're done well and we've
seen this happen before as well when
cameron and david davis ended up
battling it out in the final it was
actually a very good process for the
party ideas were brought forward people
said by the way i remember that campaign
at the beginning of the campaign oh this
is going to be brutal oh everyone's
going to be sort of bashing the heck out
of each other in fact that's not what
happened in the end i think here the
same will be true of course sometimes
they'll be you know lively debate but in
the end i think you know and i certainly
know this will be the case with rishi he
will put forward the positive case
others can put forward their case what's
wrong with with offering votes to others
you know why is that such a bad thing
has somebody quite close to you quite
recently once said there's the brakes
well look simply in this case it just
didn't happen i think the the idea was
are you sure yes the idea and not only
am i sure the person that was suggested
which was jeremy hunt
himself says every single person on his
nomination paper to somebody who's very
close to his campaign so even he's
rubbished it look again i i don't want
to
let's just focus on the positives i i i
okay let's do that then talk to me about
uh rishi sunax that's very slick video
how long do you think it took him to cut
that um i i don't think he personally
cut it at all but i know it wasn't
filmed until wednesday so he'd already
resigned okay and and he wasn't planning
to be prime minister until he resigned
he hadn't got a campaign up and running
he didn't have people in the background
working for him he didn't have an office
well what i what i think is is the case
is that he was becoming
increasingly concerned about the uh
uh direction of of travel there had been
a
long series of missteps as far as he was
concerned and i i don't think it would
make sense to pretend otherwise we know
that was the case um
but uh you know in terms of the video as
you say in terms of sort of actually
pulling the campaign to together
that part of it is um from from post his
resignation i know specifically the
video was filmed on wednesday okay on
wednesday i'm sure not all of it was um
i'm sure not all of it was there
there was stock footage in there from
the 1960s you're right some of it
already yeah and other stuff had been
filmed before as well that they didn't
knock that together in such a short
period of time unless you can prove
otherwise uh well i i think i'll come on
the filmmaking come on and tell me
exactly
i know how to make telly i know how to
make those movies and it takes a little
bit longer
all i know is especially wrote to
johnson
uh last week questioning his competence
his honesty and his seriousness then
yesterday um he said you know he's the
best thing since sliced bread so why is
he doing that why is he changing his
look
again i think that um it's clear that
you can both be
brilliant as an individual and also be
flawed and as rishi pointed out as i
pointed out
in many times actually over the last
year or two um you know boris johnson
was a is a brilliant individual who did
many remarkable things including getting
us through this brexit nightmare that we
lived through but not six years anymore
doing the the the vaccine uh what's
happened with uh with the ukraine and
the way that he's been the one one of
the principal leaders in the world but
you know obviously made mistakes and you
know like all of us you can both be
great and flawed and afraid it applies
to every single one of us i mean there
are no exceptions to that either no
there are not however being prime
minister um it would appear that he
still has quite a lot of grassroots
support and so rishi sunak has been at
reading the runes and thinking i need to
not knife him in the back anymore
look i i just don't agree with that at
all rishi
myself others we all work very very
closely with the prime minister and even
right through to um to to to close to
the end to try to pull things round to
try to rescue a situation which over a
period of time well in the background he
was organizing his own campaign just in
case well look look look as i say um you
know your particular allegation about
the video i think is is wrong but we'll
see you know
i i all i know is rishi sat down and
recorded it on on on wednesday as i
understand things um but clearly
anybody could see that there were
problems anybody could see that things
were going wrong that does not detract
from the fact that boris johnson has
been remarkable in many ways and it's a
huge sadness to to many people many
voters myself included as a member of
his cabinet that he wasn't able to pull
around and as you know i personally
um thought that despite you know some
issues misgiving some shortcomings uh i
actually thought uh his advantages
outweighed okay the uk ambassador to
ukraine sat where you are last week and
said they're going to crowdfund to have
him in ukraine because if we don't want
him they will well i know i speak to my
opposite number uh alexander kubrickov
who's the infrastructure a transport
minister in in ukraine and he's a huge
fan of boris johnson but even more so
he's a fan of the way that this
government has responded to ukraine and
i'm one thing i'm absolutely sure about
is if rishi and i imagine even other
people were elected ukraine would be
front and foremost of their plan in fact
rishi's a bit busy
our economy as well i was going to say
rishi's funded 2.3 billion pounds to
that battle talk to me about um our
infrastructure uh what on earth is going
on with our airports and airlines well
i've been very concerned about the way
that the um their bounce back or over
bounce back in in a sense from cove it
has caused all those cues and
you know uh problems at the airport i've
been working with them we've got a
22-point plan
that we've put together with the um
sector which has included changing the
law to speed up things like the
processing of uh
of security clearances using some brexit
freedoms as it happens
and ask the airports and the airlines to
be realistic about the program that they
run the flight program that they run all
in order to ensure that when the schools
break up for the summer
across the whole country and they
already have in parts in scotland for
example
that we see the airports run as smoothly
as possible that i should point out this
is not a uk only problem the same issues
care about that i don't care about
what's happening
which country which airport do you think
according to our data that we've just
done which airport do you think is the
worst i can't let you just dismiss the
international nature of it aircraft
flight which
do you think is that well i can't
because it's my program okay you can't
because yeah aircraft flight around the
world what do you think is the worst
effort i have to finish this point
aircraft fly around the world and when
they do the delays other places also
create which do you think is the worst
airport in the uk well several airports
have had problems manchester has been
very well published i i i don't know
which is the worst depends how you
measure it depends okay
who do you think cancel most clients
again you tell me if you've got a number
or depend how you you judge it we know
that manchester's have problems we know
that gatwicks have problems we know that
heathrow of shores and there uh have
lessened the number of flights that they
have as well do you feel that you've
been concentrating enough on what's
happening on our railways given that
you've been running a leadership
campaign absolutely i mean i've been
working so the train drivers are going
on strike now as well well the train
drivers whose average salary median
salary is nearly 60 000 pounds a year
doesn't take away from the point i've
made i i just don't believe that this is
the right time for them to strike the
public everybody watching this every
household pays 600 pounds each to keep
them all in jobs uh and all off furlough
still going
to do better and i don't think that is
uh justified and one of the things which
i've talked about before
is we have to modernize our railways we
can't have a situation where we can't
run services at the weekends because we
aren't allowed to put it in the contract
that sometimes you work a weekend we're
not asking people to work seven days so
we have to modernize the railways then
we'll be able to get a settlement at
sixty thousand pounds nearly average
salary a year i think the public will be
at the time we're gonna have to leave it
there we've got lots of things left up
in the air hopefully we'll see you again
very soon and we'll see what happens
thanks very much indeed